it's almost time to ring in the New Year
and once again Las Vegas has the biggest
the bestest the baddest New Year's Eve
party in the entire world 8 news now is
going to ring in the new year with a Big
Show from coast to coast from The Palms
Hotel Resort right here in town the
casino and once again hosting our big
program you can see them on your screen
they're already dancing it's comedian
and actor Michael Yo and TV personality
Nikki Novak welcome guys welcome back to
Las Vegas how's it going
what's up how are you so excited we're
excited we're excited too so let's talk
about the big program this year what can
people expect
they can expect wins number one yes
well that's the thing with live TV you
never know what's going to happen right
we're gonna be three plus hours live on
the air what they can expect is we're
gonna kick off the show in Times Square
with the fireworks display there at
midnight and then we're gonna count down
three more midnights across the country
ending of course here in the best place
and you guys know you're Vegas we have
the best fireworks show in the country
shooting off all of the you know top of
the resorts and it's just going to be a
huge party we can't wait that's right
now we can't wait for it either looking
forward to it hopefully the wind and the
rain steer clear though but we're
talking about a big long program aside
from the fireworks shows this is a big
show there's a lot of big performances a
lot of big acts a lot of big
entertainers as well
yes the ax will blow you away
we have Casey Donahue a phenomenal
country artist we have Belinda uh
Carlisle will be on the show and also
Motley Crue they're my favorite yeah
such a thing Michael's going to put on
his tight white pants his sailor hat and
he's gonna dance for you guys all night
long he's probably gonna end up in the
pool I will I will end up in the pool
this is just a party spot because look
we all live in Vegas we know it goes
down here better than anywhere else in
the country so we're excited to be apart
tune in for the tight white pants but
stay for the Motley Crew I guess is the
lesson of the day so this is a big
National broadcast here guys how can
people who are watching at home get
involved
okay you don't have to ask Michael twice
what did they you want to be involved
well let me show you got it so so Mikey
Minden uh a huge choreographer to the
Stars I mean he's designed the Pussycat
Dolls Oscars Emmys he did our opening
dance and I was in it and I had
background dances behind me and we did
this dance that you can do online right
now all you got to do is go to your
station's website and learn to dance
with me and then we will put you on the
show it's just that simple so we do a
little this right here you know we do oh
I'm losing my oh we do we do the cup
I'm too see the wire is holding me
the wire is holding me back yes the
website learn the web learn the dancing
yes everything's going on everything's
going on but learn to dance send it to
us and it'll be all good and we're as
you mentioned you're at the Palms right
now it's a fantastic property we know it
well here in Las Vegas but why the Palms
this year
The Palms is sort of the place to be
like behind us at the pool right now
um it's you know it's bare right now but
we're gonna have acrobatics we're gonna
have dancers like I said Michael's gonna
be on the pool day on day who's a
world-renowned DJ is going to be
cranking the music we have also so many
surprises and you know the Palms is just
such a fun place to celebrate
um this is just the place to be and
we're we have the best view of the
fireworks which we're going to be
bringing to you did we just want you
guys to be part of the party feel like a
VIP bring in the new year with us and
here's the thing we're just gonna hang
with you this is not like a host that
comes on and says we're just two people
that want to hang out with you and give
you the best New Year's Eve possible if
you can't leave the house sounds good
Michael Yo Nikki Novak joining us from
the palms for the big New Year's Eve
program look forward to seeing you guys
on New Year's Eve thanks